the title of this video is are the
writings of Ellen White on the same
level as the Bible no they're above the
Bible in adventism they are above the
Bible they are Jesus supposedly speaking
and they are infallible not just this
but they are the infallible guide to
interpreting the
[Music]
Bible what's up y'all as always welcome
to the channel I'm back with another
reaction video that a viewer submitted
and wanted us to respond to if there's a
video like this that you want to see us
respond to let us know in the comments
down below this time we are looking at a
video where SDA conspiracy theorist
Walter VI is answering the question are
Ellen White's writings on the same level
as the Bible let's see what he says the
Bible is the ultimate greater light the
Bible is the one whereby all standards
of Doctrine and behavior needs to be
measured so the spirit of Prophecy
can place a light on the greater light
so it is a lesser light giving emphasis
to certain portion of scriptures and
making them come alive that's basically
what it does it doesn't replace the word
of God it doesn't uh expand upon the
word of God other than
placing more light at the exposure or to
expose more light out of the words of
the Bible yeah no the Bible is not the
ultimate greater light in adventism I
know they love to do the whole greater
light lesser light thing because that's
what Ellen White claimed but she doesn't
have the greatest reputation of being a
logician just think about how silly that
is folks someone doesn't need a
flashlight when they're in the sun we
don't need the SDA flashlight but either
way notice and we've looked at this
before the review in Herald June 3rd 19
71 to be reliable interpretation must
come to us through the same channel
through which came the scripture in the
first place but what is the channel
through which scripture came to us the
testimony of Jesus or the spirit of
Prophecy it was the spirit of Jesus that
spoke through the prophets and then
notice the pole quote the Bible is an
infallible guide but it needs to be
infallibly interpreted to avoid
confusion and division so the SDA Church
claims the spirit of Prophecy is where
Jesus is speaking they claim this takes
place in alen white writings hence why
they use the term Spirit of Prophecy to
refer to her writings and very clearly
they claim that in order to properly
interpret the Bible you have to have the
infallible interpreter the what the
infallible interpreter which would mean
that yes you guys have put Mrs White's
writings over scripture because you
can't even understand and interpret
scripture correctly without her so I
agree she's not on the same level as
scripture she's above scripture it's
also why the statement of confidence in
her writings which is something that the
uh General Conference puts out every
General Session it openly States this
look the SDA Church reaffirms their
conviction that Ellen White's writings
are divinely inspired truly Christ
centered and bible-based rather than
replacing the Bible they uplift the
normative character of scripture and
correct inaccurate interpretations of it
derived from tradition human reason
personal experience and modern culture
so Walter we can't use the B as the
standard to measure all Doctrine and
behavior because we can't even
understand it correctly without your
guys's prophetess the Lesser light to
light the way for us to the greater
light and to claim that she never adds
anything to the Bible but only ever
expounds upon what's there is rather
Rich considering you guys have an entire
great controversy worldview that entails
a prear origin story that scripture
knows nothing of show us in the Bible
that Satan was able to twist the Heart
of Jesus Jesus while he was on the cross
causing him to doubt his resurrection
and if his sacrifice would be accepted
show us in Scripture that Satan made an
accusation against God's law in heaven
prior to the creation of the earth and
God is now vindicating his character
before all the universe to silence
Satan's accusations while you're at it
by all the universe that includes all
these other beings on these unfallen
worlds show us all that in the Bible
they can't because what they mean by
this is that since the Bible will simply
say things like there was war in heaven
and Lucifer fell from heaven Ellen White
then fills in details that are not found
in the Bible but they're not in addition
because she's commenting on General
statements in the Bible this is just
word games yes she adds all sorts of
stuff to scripture not found there which
is why they have to funnel all of
scripture through their extra biblical
Great controversy theme which comes from
Ellen White who claimed it came from God
Adventists need to own up to this and be
honest and then defend that Ellen White
is an infallible interpreter drives me
crazy when they do this song and dance
when the sources make it clear as day
yet they'll still try and argue it
typically by insulting your intelligence
and claiming that you lack reading
comprehension so if people had studied
the Bible and kept strictly to the Bible
and the Bible alone and what it says
then they would have been no need for a
spirit of Prophecy so in other words
what the spirit of Prophecy does is to
say very plainly what some people
obscure regarding the word of God if
people had stuck with the Bible there'd
be no need for the spirit of Prophecy
AKA Adventist in the 19th century were
the only ones really studying the Bible
it's almost comical when they when they
assert stuff like this because their
system of theology is so fundamentally
flawed and broken and it's full full of
theological nooms and Relics of the 19th
century that are apparently just plain
in scripture everybody else through all
the centuries prior to them was just too
stupid to see them they weren't really
studying the Bible but that's actually
what's consistent with this because if
you if you recall we've looked at this
before Ellen White claimed that they
were rewarded with light from Heaven
because of their diligence in studying
the Bible no one was really studying the
Bible until the Adventist came along who
have this special Insight now that they
were gifted because of their diligence
not he just played word games he said
the writings of Ellen White simply shed
light onto scripture and make clear what
others obscure about the word of God AKA
she is an infallible interpreter and you
need her writings to be able to
correctly interpret the Bible if your
interpretation doesn't jive with hers
you're wrong she's right and you have to
agree with her he literally just said
what's in the review and Herald article
just in a more uh obfuscatory way the
title of this video is are the writings
of Ellen White on the same level as the
Bible no they're above the Bible they
are Jesus supposedly speaking and they
are infallible not just this but they
are the infallible guide to interpreting
the Bible that would be the honest
answer instead they play these semantic
games of lesser light and greater light
which makes no sense anyways I don't
need a flashlight when I'm in the sun
and the question of
inspiration now that is a very very
controversial
question uh
there is the position that she has the
same inspiration as the biblical
prophets but some within our ranks would
say that she doesn't have the same
Authority now that is a bit of an
oxymoron because if you're going to have
the same
inspiration then
surely the the measure of authority is
part of of the package wouldn't you
say because inspiration without
Authority really becomes meaningless if
God is
speaking through an individual then that
is the voice of God so does the voice of
God have less Authority in some people
than in other people and the the answer
to that must obviously be no right which
is why what you just said only three
minutes ago doesn't jive with this her
writings aren't on the same level as the
Bible they insist they're just authored
by the same holy spirit that authored
the scriptures and she was inspired no
differently than the biblical
writers he just recognized that when God
speaks he speaks there's not a hierarchy
of levels when it comes to that when God
speaks it's equal with every other time
he speaks because what gives those words
their status and Authority is the one by
whom they are spoken God himself so if
Ellen White's writings are where Jesus
is speaking supposedly then yes that is
on the same level as scripture but
actually above scripture because they're
the infallible interpreter of scripture
so cut it out with the mental gymnastics
and just own it this explains why
adventism is such a confused mess of
cognitive dissonance they need to just
own that yes they believe Ellen White's
writings are equal with the Bible in
Authority they aren't in addition to the
Bible but they are an infallible
interpretive guide where Jesus himself
is speaking giving the correct
interpretation of the Bible instead they
do these semantic games so as far as I
am concerned she is authoritive and
there are many people that will try to
water down that
Authority uh there are people in the
world that believe that
inspiration has to be verbal in other
words God dictates to a person what that
person has to say God doesn't work like
that you can study your Bible he has
never operated like that in any shape or
form because God created us with a mind
and with freedom of
choice and he will never
circumvent our cognitive capacity he
will never coers he will never Force so
what the prophet PHS envisioned and what
they saw they wrote down in their own
words according to the best capacity
that they had and this is how we must
read alen G white no sir that is not how
the Bible describes God's word it
doesn't describe God's word as the
prophet's words where they conveyed to
the best of their ability what God
showed them no God breathed means god
breathed
it means God's words not the prophet's
words and it doesn't make them an
automaton they love doing this they
always try and paint things as like you
know the other people out there that
don't agree with us they have this real
Sinister view it doesn't matter what
topic it is they do this all over the
place they have this wrong view of God
that he's this Tyrant dictator and he
controls people what the uh yeah when
God is the one that's uh communicating
using his own words he's using a vessel
to convey his own words that doesn't
make him automaton he's using a broken
stick to strike a straight blow the
human being was an instrument in his
hands for him to communicate his own
words but at least he's honest here
because yes lots of SD try and water
down that Authority but so did Walter he
said her writings are not on the same
level of scripture which I agree they're
above scripture they have to be utilized
to actually understand the correct
interpretation of Any Given passage but
then he gets into inspiration as if that
even has anything to do with the problem
here this is the same thing that Jud
Lake appeals to in his book Ellen White
Under Fire that people's criticisms of
Ellen White are invalid because they
have this real rigid false view of
inspiration no that doesn't help you
guys the issue is not verbal dictation
over and against the whole person model
or whatever it is that they call their
their view the issue is exactly what
Walter just got done saying if it's God
speaking in both places the Bible and
Ellen White's writings then they are
ontologically the same
you then add in that she is an
infallible interpreter now her writings
are above the Bible because you can't
understand the Bible without her it's
irrelevant what mode of inspiration you
want to defend you're still saying
they're of the same Authority so when
they try and bring this up in this
context don't take the bait it is just a
sideshow to distract away from the point
and notice the tale end there he said
this is how we're to read Ellen White
this is their lowering of scripture to
subtly Elevate Ellen White's writings
she's the Baseline because she had all
sorts of errors in her writings changes
that had to be made Etc so then they
have to adopt a form of inspiration that
is fallible like she was even though
they claim she's the infallible
interpreter so don't take the bait they
are correct when they say that Ellen
White's writings are not on the same
level as the Bible they are above the
Bible though they have the same level of
authority as the Bible to see a more
thorough Deep dive on this where we
examine over 50 of Ellen White's own
statements check out our Funeral Service
of a false propit which you can access
here